hello everyone welcome to another
episode of unlocking lily so it's always
been my dream to be a speaker which led
me to quit my day job to work and mentor
under Evan full time and all of you are
coming along for this ride with me in
every episode I take on a different
challenge to help me grow as a speaker
so in this video I am going back to
Michigan where I'll be speaking at a
secular congregation called the Sunday
assembly so you're probably wondering
how did this happen why are you back
there again Lily so when I did my TEDx
talk
I caught the attention of one of the
organizers at the sunday Assembly so she
came up to me she loved the one word
talk and she wanted to see if I would
speak at her congregation and naturally
I said yes of course so I will be doing
the exact same talk but this time I'm
gonna do something a little bit
different and really challenging for me
to step outside of my comfort zone I
will be singing the intro to my talk so
you guys need to wish me luck and I'll
see you on the road
so today's a day I'm going off to
Michigan it's actually a long weekend in
Canada we're celebrating Thanksgiving I
think this is a good time for me to give
all of you thanks for being part of this
journey with me and it's just getting
started because we're going on this road
trip together to Michigan and I'm gonna
go get my husband and we're gonna hit
the road right now
[Music]
we're making a quick pit stop to refuel
our car and refuel our bellies we're
gonna go inside and try to find
something a little bit healthy doesn't
look too promising but we'll see
[Music]
Michael what did you get to eat
oh it's not healthy good morning
everyone hope everyone's having a
wonderful day and my phone died last
night so I couldn't I couldn't record
and bring you guys and we had a busy
night we we went out for dinner last
night about a Middle Eastern restaurant
here at Livonia Michigan it was really
good we got to know the organizers
better at the sunday assembly
inauguration they just a shared their
vision and hearing a little bit about
their childhood and how they discovered
themselves and how they issued certain
things and which led them to this path
so that was really good to know my phone
is well charged today are you gonna see
a lot of stuff happening today
[Music]
getting started music many white people
couple songs that make you feel very pop
or maybe right away in the morning just
minutes maybe there's now to run a
routine you're already in positivity
back to the world is so important
hey my talk is done at this sunday
assembly Detroit chapter it was such an
awesome experience I haven't experienced
anything like that before in my life
it's it's a church-like experience
without religion so it was really cool
what do you think nicest group of
atheists I've ever met I love it
I'm going to head over to a meeting with
someone that I met at the TEDx event
last month and we're gonna head home to
Toronto very soon
[Music]
so I just got back from giving your
one-word talk at the sunday assembly and
I thought I'd share two things that I
learned from this experience
number one is it feels amazing
to get over your fear I had this giant
fear of singing in public and I have no
idea why like I shunned it out from my
life to the point that I wouldn't even
sing happy birthday at someone's
birthday party when they brought out
that cake
absolutely ridiculous it's such a small
thing to do I just got so scared and
nervous primarily because I have a
terrible singing voice and I was afraid
of getting judged and that's really the
truth and I thought it's time for me to
get over this fear and what better to do
it and to do it in front of all of those
people during my hog so I sang the intro
to my talk my gosh leading up to it it
was really scary but what I was doing
I'm like wow this feels great and it's
not a big deal and when I was done with
it it felt amazing number two if people
are just awesome when I went on stage
and I told them that look I have a
sphere and I was really hoping that you
guys could help me out they were more
than helpful they all cheered me on
they all sing along with me and it was
such a
the experience and you know what I also
felt like that's what brought us even
closer together and I have a special
shadow for Clifford Starks Clifford
thank you so much for writing that
really sweet comment on my last episode
it really does mean a lot to me and
finally the question the day is what is
your favorite song to sing along to
leave in the comments below and I'll
join in on the discussion I received
some amazing news my TEDx talk your word
word is out now so from my next video I
will be sharing my TEDx talk with you
guys this is stay tuned for that and
thank you so much for watching and more
importantly being on this journey with
me I get so excited when I see all your
comments coming in every time my video
comes out so keep them coming and I'll
keep answering them
and I'll see you guys very very soon the
most important word ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple so it
would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details